I'm going to start with them quick few
slides and just explain like what I'm
going to talk about what aims this
tutorial is what I'm not going to give
this is not an entire graduate level
seminar or like masters and statistics
unfortunately cannot compress that into
an hour and a half I've tried um and so
firstly Who am I I'm senior data
scientist at channel 4 we're sponsoring
and we're a media company we leverage
data for targeted advertising customer
analytics recommendation engines we're
hiring a junior role so have a chat if
you're interested I'll be around here
all weekend and what else do i do so I'm
an open source contributor to PI mc3
those are you do not know what I mc3 is
this good luck here we're having oil
that's going to involve a lot about it
it's a bayesian Markov chain Monte Carlo
framework of mathematics statistics
background and I'm in too many different
societies and I wrote a book and it's
not selling well but at some point
during the conference I will harass you
about that and take it make you buy it
right so statistics is everywhere and I
was at an event a television event few
weeks ago and this came up this survey
and it's say them it was of course in
numerous media outlets and and it says
just 1% of man takes shared parental
leave and and of course I listening to
radio for I came across a question but
what's wrong with us not kill anybody in
the audience guess what was wrong with
the survey the survey actually looked at
all men regardless of whether or not
they were likely to have children or not
so there you know it took like a large
population sample rather than people who
were like to of course this got rehashed
like you know it lies damn lies and
statistics the famous a quote from years
ago in Victorian era but this got pulled
around unused for political ends right
that was the other thing I could you use
to reinforce certain stereotypes and
argue against Sharon
leave so for those of you who who want
to log into this you can go to the BBC
website and they have their more or less
program run by tim harford an excellent
economist and he talks about like how
the Sturm it couldn't be example it was
actually using like off-the-shelf survey
tool and they hadn't thought about how
the statistics was gathering stuff like
this so that's kind of an argument to
put into context of like as data
scientist or data engineers we generally
will be using statistical tools and we
have to be very careful about what
questions we ask on what these question
you know what we can answer with our
models or our samples or our hypothesis
testing very easy to just imports I pie
and forget to think logically about what
you're actually trying to solve so
hopefully by the end of this tutorial
you'll have a few tricks up your sleeve
and we're going to talk about mostly
logistic regression we're going to talk
about it from mu pie mc3 and
scikit-learn and in stats models and
this is all is the kind of question I
wake up in the middle of night and
wander by and I'm not going to teach you
salsa tistic seeeeee in like an hour and
a half you have to make these things
clear at the very start of a talk okay
so these are the outcomes of the
tutorial we're going to have three
different tools to attack the same
problem I'm largely given this tutorial
cuz Ian like convince me to do it and by
saying wouldn't it be great if you give
a tutorial on this and then before I
know what I had volunteered and we're
going to have some tricks tips and
tricks like hypothesis testing a feature
selection but not too much about this
and we're going to talk a little bit
about how to interpret and debug three
versions of logistic regression the
machine learning way you're in the
scikit-learn paradigm the frequentist
statistics way what you may know from
school and the bayesian way which you
probably don't know from school unless
you went to a very particular
universally it's often not taught and
for those of you who are looking for the
link I set up a bitly link with PI data
as
that's honest so one thing I noticed at
conferences like this is that we do have
like a very much of a shame learning
focus you know there's a huge amount of
investment in academia into machine
learning versus other ends of Statistics
you and there's like this concert thing
because of the Big Data paradigm and all
these sort of memes that we're talking
about and we forget that there are tools
I have developed over many many years
you know bayesian statistics go back to
about 1850 roughly you know and you know
frequented statistics you know back to
certainly the early 20th century you
know these have been refined and they
have a place in your toolbox so doing
this under the assumption that most
people in the audience are machine
learning practitioners could I show of
hands anyone who identifies as a machine
learning focus person okay anyone who
identifies as a statistician okay I'm
definitely in trouble with you guys and
anyone who identifies as a bayesian I
mean yes great is one and we should
definitely talk um but what the rest of
you guys like you know randoms from the
street like you know like hey Shirley
like I know I've just invented three
categories off the top of my head here
but like you know what you know the rest
is just general engineers academics how
many academics okay so a lot of people
really don't know what category they're
in but that's a different story um okay
so am Vincent who's actually in the
audience I stolen this from him but I
told them um but this is like the it's a
nice diagram of the different schools of
data right so you have your frequentist
you have your bayesian you have a
machine learning a lot of discussions
will be around at this event will be
around here you things that support
vector machines you how to like deal
with precision and recall lease or
things there will be a few bayesian
talks i think um because i think there's
a few other people speaking this weekend
and i'm not so sure by frequentist talks
here but I welcome more if they
there aren't enough so these are
characters three different tool boxes
and the aim of this is if you know one
of these three you'll be able to learn
the other one or two and I kind of use
the one you know as a reference point
for how you will approach the same
problem in a different tool kit okay so
first thing I do hypothesis testing and
of course those of you who are physics
geeks will know that I took one of
einstein's hypothesis was recently
proved your conferred by eight
empiricism an illegal experiment and a
lot of that was done on top of em Python
ecosystem using ipython notebooks and of
course Stan which is a domain-specific
language for bayesian statistics so the
sort of things that you support by
attending conferences like this were
used to confirm genius German and his
honors excellent work so the other thing
is that we're going to like um you know
talk about like you know we generally
talk about normal linear regression I'm
only going to talk with logistic
regression and this talk and you're
going to talk with these three schools
scikit-learn starts models and pi RC 3
i'm giving you guys all time to get set
up as well here and you've bayesian
tooling and there's most of the tutorial
we based on one of the darkest of
documentation and that is up online on
the PI n c3 and website so now I time to
show some code I've talk for long enough
so for those of you who have downloaded
they the code there's two there is a
notebooks folder and in the notebooks
folder there's two files one of the
files is logistic regression could
everyone see this so it's fine for
everyone so what the first file is
logistic regression and as is always the
case you just we do their standard
imports you know for scikit-learn
we input linear model and your training
tests that I don't assume everyone the
audience knows on the train test that is
otherwise there are other talks during
this weekend that you can go to and I
use the data from the UCI the University
of California Irvine and that's the
adult data set it's a survey from I
think the 1950s but you know how much
people are earning what they're working
in stuff like this it's just a nice data
set and you can pick any other one so
the first thing that we do of course you
know is we have to like remove all the
noles in income so you don't want if you
want to be predict something on income
you don't want to be predicting on
Noel's I say this because even after a
few years of doing machine learning I
still run into this ballast mistake of
like forgetting to deal with nolles in
the column and we're restricting only to
the United States for reasons of
easiness
I'm glad you're in the front row and of
course we're all trying to download the
data from the ECI website I hope this
survives this tutorial as well because
that would be quite embarrassing
okay is everyone following who wants to
follow along following along does anyone
need if not a couple of minutes I'm fine
to give you another couple minutes i can
talk very fast at you do you want to
follow you don't want to follow them oh
thank you James yeah it's great to be
heckled here and it's less early in the
morning sorry sorry I can't hear you um
it's in the slack channel um here if I
show this again they're bit bit ly / PI
data LDN starts to that should get you
to my repository okay no problem here to
help so the first thing we do is of
course we have to create a binary
variable which is very easy I picked
greater than 50k for reasons of
randomness you can pick whatever you
want this is just a classical use case
of using logistic regression this could
be a churn model this could be whatever
else you want to work on the other thing
I do which is a standard trick is to
square you know your your age variable
you're assuming that you have some
relationship basing this on some other
work I did like analyzing the data set
before but this is the kind of standard
trick you would do with a numeric
variable like this assuming that you
have like a nonlinear relationship
between this and the thing you're trying
to predict and some of this you can do
randomly some of this you can do
systematically some of this you do out
of habit um so we restrict the data set
to stuff that we could actually use we
look at the income we've got class and
balance here it's actually quite
difficult to see but here you have a lot
more zeroes than ones right so you're
trying to predict on a class imbalance
data set reason i picked this is that
this is a very classical problem real
life is generally not balanced
thing to predict on if you if you use
good practice you do lots of plots if
you don't use good practice you should
do lots of plots and seaborne mix it's
very easy and you can have an idea of
what data set you're dealing with this
is just like as an approach standard
best practice approach for for
predicting things and so because you
have in psychic learn you have the
logistic regression you have a few
parameters and the first one here I've
just changed the constant to something
very high I'm just doing this to have a
feel for like you know and this is
probably awesome like generic first
logistic regression that I applied to
any problem I am we can ignore those
errors because I don't have time to deal
with this but but you know one and in
the machine learning part and we have
scores right so we have scores of
accuracy so the first thing we do is we
we look at the score of our accuracy on
the training set so that's about eighty
percent which is not great it's not
amazing it's not anything you use in a
fraud detection problem not unless you
want to lose lots of money but you know
it's it's good enough for a lot of
problems and then you compare it to your
kind of a your your your your worst case
scenario the dummy variable so we've
decent predictions but not great ones
only twenty four percent of the class
earns more than 50 K which means that
you could obtain seventy-six percent
accuracy by always predicting note so
we're doing slightly better than the
null error rate but not much so the next
thing you kind of do is you you'll
evaluate your coefficients so this is a
standard approach that you have in a
machine learning problem you're looking
at your coefficients you're looking at
how they're related with the thing
you're trying to predict you're seeing
if there's any insights you can get out
of there
so so that's kind of like your standard
workflow the one thing I haven't done so
far is I haven't really split things
into a training set and our task set but
nobody corrected me on that which is
clearly indicated as far too early in
the morning so so I have a slightly
different model which is the class that
the normal the default settings and then
I want to predict things like my class
model oh I'm not too quick and then I
want to do things like generate my
probabilities just to show some of the
functionality and psychic learn so we
can look at this mall as a black box I'm
obviously not going to talk too much
about machine learning feel because my
whole agenda with the talk was talking
with pi n c3 but big surprise but you
know this is the kind of standard
workflow you'd have we're all familiar
with this this is you know what we do
some of you in the audience are going
and I should plot more often and what
yes yes you should um and you'll untie
us you know there is a good robust
paradigm here that you can use to score
and understand a problem but this is a
this is very much a computer science
centric way of looking at the world
right you know there's no there's no
where there's no uncertainties here you
know we don't have any notion of our
uncertainty and the thing we're modeling
we have like a black box kind of thing
that were we're accepting you know will
work now it does work because some of us
make a lot of money and some companies
make a lot of money are using machine
learning I'm not arguing that we should
abandon machine learning but I'm saying
that for some problems particular ones
that you want to interpret and
understand the phenomena there are other
tools mostly from the world statistics
so is everyone following along am I
talking too fast do you understand my
accent all these are questions and gun
yeah its class imbalance their sauce yes
Vicki what would you do just use the
weights yeah yeah yeah you can also do
things like you can I would I wish I'd
put more stuff a model model debugging
but I didn't have time
there should be a talks over this
weekend on that we can have definitely
have a chat about the different ways
that you can look at that you can look
at the individual things and like and
plot you know using like a heat map or
something to see if we're in particular
your your misclassifying things and then
you can also do things like hyper
parameter tuning which is something
which I didn't have time to go into like
to actually find the optimum parameters
for that problem that's kind of the only
ways i can think of the top of my head
you can like normalize your your balance
sets as well that's one way of
approaching it but this is kind of an
entire phenomena as well like an entire
era of like modernity machine learning
research of you know because because of
things like fraud detection problems and
stuff like this if you can find anybody
who works for a fraud detection company
which there are probably definitely
people in this room I'm definitely
people at this conference they may be
able to tell you even more tricks that
they have up their sleeve for dealing
with that I hope that's a good enough
answer okay so um so I'm really not
going to run through all this code here
life because I know this will be a good
way for something to break and the
things you learn giving talks you never
do live demos so if you if you open up
the document take the other one the
statistics this is where the real meat
of my of my talk is the first thing I'm
going to talk about is a bit heavy and
difficult I do this because it's early
in the morning I want to wake everybody
up but you know it's bayesian a/b
testing it's from a match a cooler and
who's that list it's it's on his blog on
the list blog it's a standard use case
of where he simulates an a you know the
results were Navy test by assuming like
a beta binomial distribution which is a
fairly representative distribution for
what will happen in an a/b test because
most people you know people do not
follow up Gaussian distribution you have
these kind of different distributions
out there and and he uses that to
generate them sample data from an
experiment
and he has things like your treatment
are your observed icon then the other
thing he does like and this is them for
those of you who've never use PI mc3 in
PI mc3 you always have this with model
syntax and this is a context manager
within this you specify your parameters
so here there's on the blog there's an
entire equation like of what you would
do it I didn't want to put too many in
quai shins because I didn't want to
scare everybody out of the room and it
happens and then you know this is your
prior Sigma your treatment Sigma the
control mean is something that's a
distribution that he's already specified
the treatment effect is the thing that
we want to find which is the difference
in means right so the difference between
your control me and your treatment mean
this is the thing that you're really
trying to get our a/b test this could be
for example our conversion rate right
because most of the time with these kind
of test you're looking for the
difference into statistics to see if
something is actually reasonable or not
or something is statistically
significant and then there's kind of
there's other stuff that you have to do
to get to get the stuff into a model and
the other thing that you have is you
have and you have outcome and your I
come here it's a thing that you're
actually going to simulate this is your
really your likelihood am here in PI mc3
you have to specify your number of
samples if you use something called the
maximum a posture dare I and algorithm
this is defined the starting point
because it's very important but where
you start this simulation I use
metropolis which is a standard algorithm
and and then you just get your Chi of
your trace I had to discard some of the
burning because the first part of the
simulation didn't work for didn't
converge very well and then you can I
put this all into a data frame so this
might be a bit heavy for you right now
but we will learn more about this we
will whenever
we go through the logistic regression
stuff later I just didn't really know
where to put this in the top so you can
generate your data then you can fit your
priors and then you have your your
treatment me and one of the things
you're going to observe is that the
treatment effect which is a thing that
we're trying to need look for this is
our effect has as a minimum value
negative which makes no sense in this
kind of test you would not expect to
have a negative effect so clearly this
here model is crap you know we should
never use this am but this is a kind of
thing that you'll notice whenever you're
debugging these care models it's very
easy I know in his blog piece he goes
through like you know the need to
specify priors in a more clever way and
high constantly looking at output can
evaluate this is just a way to show you
of the kind of failures and risks that
you have whenever you apply this
approach and hopefully before the end of
the talk we'll talk a little bit more
about your highly debug these models I
just wanted to show you something
rubbers first and then try to gradual
your better stuff so if you want to play
around you can just run through that
model and change sup with one of your
priors and then run of the game and see
what happens but because it's a large
audience are quite difficult to keep
everybody's attention you might want not
what to do that but I'll give you a
couple of minutes if you want does
anyone have any questions right now I
know that's a bit heavy right now and
that was just like to show you like as a
proper use case we're going to go
through this stuff in a bit more slower
detail now we're going to look at
hypothesis testing first and infrequent
istics using mostly scifi and then we're
going to look at hypothesis testing and
PI mc3 and then we're going to look at
machine learning frequented sophistic
and pi mc3 for logistic regression
um yeah I love when people ask me that
question and so there is there are there
are like rules of thumb is one thing
particularly from like biostatistics and
like experimental work there are also
studies about like you know there's
things like something called a Jeffrey
prior which I forget what it is off the
top of my head but there are ways of
picking that um but unfortunately every
time I look into the literature I do
discover this kind of like there's a
subjective aspect of that you know and I
don't think there are algorithms in the
same way that there are hyper parameter
pecking algorithms in machine learning
like that you can like find the optimal
hyperparameters for your problem in
Beijing sistex but that's kind of a
research area that I'm not an expert on
and the way I was taught it was that
you're as your domain knowledge gets
better off a phenomenal you just get
better at packing your priors but there
is also the converse thing which is that
by pecking uniform priors that are like
like non informative priors this is
what's going to happen if I talk too
long and step back yeah it's okay that's
right um you know then as you get more
data for a problem that becomes less and
less important so you get that kind of
like Peter Norvig said like the more you
know data becomes more important than
algorithms in a certain class of
problems let those seem to be true in
the Bayesian context as well I hope
that's a satisfactory answer and I
haven't completely filled you off okay
so we're all going to go back to school
and isn't a terrifying prospect and
we're going to talk about hypothesis
testing right so this example is
shamelessly stolen from Chris album and
this is roughly speaking well maybe test
is right you have have an a you have it
be you want to see if they are
there's a statistical significance in
their difference so the first thing you
do is we're going to generate a you know
a random X which is uniformly
distributed and of course I have an
imported numpy seriously nobody do live
demos they're really bad idea right okay
that's fine so you have this and you can
see this is a uniform distribution in
the same way that if you're picking a
uniform prior you're in a bayesian
context it would look roughly like this
right and the other thing we're going to
do is we're going to pick another
distribution which is definitely not
uniformly distributed you definitely
tell this is not a uniform distribution
I have no idea what this distribution
would be cold and I'm sure someone named
it the first thing you're going to do is
inside pie there are loads of
statistical tests I'm going to say
something that is controversial which is
that you should just probably use calma
Gore of smirnoff because it's a pretty
good test and whichever one you like use
it whichever one you don't like to lose
it they have their strengths and
weaknesses I don't have time to go into
all the details there are statistics
experts you can get in water stones or
Amazon or whatever or talk to me over
the weekend and from this you can see
that by the we want the second return
value to not be statistically
significant meaning that they both came
from the same distribution so we've
confirmed that X our first distribution
is a uniform distribution so as an
exercise I want you to change that line
acne or the uniform to something else
you can put normal I need look of
documentation to know what the solutions
are there but by noemi or whatever and
compare it that's the kind of thing you
can do just to get used to to using this
if you've never used Syfy for a 4am
statistical test before
so the reason we use is as nonparametric
so it doesn't have any of these like
assumptions built into it one of the
things you will discover as you look at
these statistical techniques is although
the algorithms are very easy to use and
roughly speaking at one line of code
there's a lot of assumptions baked in to
hire their use and how they're not used
and so for the second one we can see
that the p-type p value is less than or
point five and there we can say that Y
is definitely not a uniform distribution
if you do a/b testing professionally or
your work in pharmaceuticals you spend a
lot of time doing examples like this and
that sounds like really lots of fun the
other thing you can do is one of the
standard t tests but you know this is a
frequent this way so I'm bayesian I
don't care like frequent ism so you know
but I was showing us as an example these
are the kind of standard tests that you
would do to better understand you know
you know the results of an a/b test a
classical example in e-commerce is there
a bayesian way to do this and there is
an algorithm or method called Bayesian
estimate estimation supersedes the
t-test like which clearly has a base
acronym ever you know BST um this is
this is from Thomas Vicki's example and
it's based on paper by John crooks and I
think that's how you pronounce his name
and he wrote a book a bayesian book
forget the title off that has dogs on
the column on the front cover it was a
really good introduction to be easy and
stuff not just because those dogs on the
front cover but that is one of the
reasons i pick it um and and in this you
will see um you will see we're going to
do the same metal you can see this is
also a lot more involved right so in the
previous example i had one line of code
now i have like lots and lots of lines
of code of setting up my priors and
setting up my likelihood and all these
sort of things um and that's a that's a
little bit
irritating but we could probably fix up
so if anyone wants to be daring enough
to run that and see if it actually works
I'd be loved as of to hear
so that's running that will take like
minutes and minutes there's anyone of
any questions right now where we are
everyone's following roughly kind of
understanding what I'm talking about um
no one has any installation difficulties
that's that's amazing actually no one's
actually I haven't that's never happened
before um so you see that's so nice but
it's greater than fifty percent through
its it's going to be about 30 seconds to
run this whole thing unless I have I
think that will be it and and in the in
the pie mc3 stuff we have them you can
look at your traces now it does anyone
see anything wrong with this model on
the right
you'll see here that like for these
different parameters that i'm like sorry
these different models i'm trying to
simulate the convergence isn't very good
right so this should be like you're
entirely smooth rather than like
stopping a right here am so this dis
models far from perfect this is one of
the things that you'll look at if you
want to build Bayesian models about like
you know the good performance you'll
look for like and in the documentation
you'll find examples are actually good
and you will see like you lots of
examples of good convergence the ways to
do that are you either pick a better
starting point in the space that you're
trying to simulate that's unfortunately
something that we learn from experience
or by picking different sampling
algorithms some of them perform better
in different cases um I'm sure there's
literature right there but why you'd
pick it and there are definitely people
here at the weekend who know more of a
dis an idea who could probably tell you
about why you picked that versus all our
things could also be bugs in the code in
which case is probably my fault so then
the other thing you'd want to do is that
after you've looked at is that someone
it's in my code here it's from John
cedar who I think speaking this weekend
as well you know he added some nice
diagrams to through the code so so to
the plots so you can better see where
the mean was and stuff like that and of
course I didn't import that properly so
some point I'm gonna learn not to try to
do live demos but I probably won't
happen today
so the other yeah so then it's slightly
better and you can see more things here
but you know particularly where the mean
is on your on your frequency and your
difference of standard deviations so
then the other thing you want to do is
like we cook for these kind of problems
you want to look at things like auto
correlation which isn't too bad for this
model i remember correctly so it's quite
good for everything except nu minus one
and and there's other models i think i
have in the notebooks here there are
even worse than this that's kind of
thing you want you want this to go down
to zero as quickly as possible that's
kind of a good rule of thumb for this
interpretation ok so you can do so ways
too so these are the kind of things
you'll need to debug loans and basing
context and we'll move on for this now
but we should be aware of the model
isn't perfectly come on pretty much yeah
it's I think they're their theoretical
equivalent so like in in same way in
time series if you're doing a time
series model you would look at your auto
correlations to see if that would tell
you you know anything or like like that
you've got interactions there it's
pretty much the same and there's
probably some professor somewhere who
disagree with my statement there but
you're probably find professor with this
agree with any statement I make here so
so okay so now we're moving on to the
meat of the talk I think I've got like
an hour left so i might finish ahead of
time um so I like like earlier on we
download our our data store I know do
you like you
we're going to apply bayesian frequent
as and machine learning approaches to
this data set the problem is going to be
predicting income greater than 50k which
we showed earlier on in the machine
learning example is anyone still
following along that's amazing
and this will take some time
so I'll just wait for that the download
so there's a whole load of data here
it's got categorical variables of stuff
and I basically just took everything I
was numeric I know and ignored all the
categorical stuff this is not good
practice but this is a tutorial and so
what do you expect and then you want to
you want to restrict these things you're
the same as we did earlier on so we want
to talk a little bit more about doing
our feature engineering so you look at
her head through the same thing as
earlier make income into a binary
variable have your age squared and look
at your class and balance data set so
one of the things because the first
thing I'm going to do is the machine
learning example one of the things you
can do using in psychic learn is you can
look at how your features are how much
mutual information there is in your
features and this is M and I only
discovered this like last night eleven
o'clock whenever I was writing this talk
um but yeah it's actually quite cool
like so there's there's that these kind
of metrics are in there in in psychic
learn and you could use them to see if
like because one thing you don't want to
happen in this modest you don't want
redundant features like or redundant
covariance depending on which site is a
fancy ring and you know so you so this
is one way that you can look at as in
scikit-learn it's very easy to write you
know you can probably copy and paste
this and use this forever and you can
say that there's the scores aren't very
good which indicates if they were closer
to one there'll be more stronger
correlation between these variables and
therefore you could probably get rid of
one of those features there's many other
feature selection at you know algorithms
in psychic learn and you can use them if
you're building a Bayesian model what I
often do myself is I will use the
psychic learning stuff to you know
understand what my feature set is like
and use
to form what kind of logistic regression
or linear regression model I built in a
bayesian context so you can always like
just you don't have to pick a side you
can use the tools from the different
sides by the right there and this works
quite well so that the other thing like
you're the stunt like we did earlier on
is that we want to explore our data we
want to look at our correlation between
our different variables and we want to
do a machine learning model and be
boring you and I used exactly the same
as the one I did early wrong and we
score we have our accuracy we have
seventy-nine percent exactly the same as
earlier on and everybody's very happy so
believe it or not in Python there's
something called stats models it's this
horrendously neglected project and that
is aiming to bring statistics to python
Easter's if you're willing to contribute
to open source software please
contribute to that one protective if you
have expertise but that's journey not a
barrier to entry am but and this is a
and you because there's lots of things
like a nice documentation you know it's
got like a release coming through but
it's actually got a lot of good stuff
there a lot of people think that you
have to like meet our or something else
or Julia whatever it is cool these days
and I'm to do statistics but you know we
have logistic regression good
frequentist logistic regression in stats
models with good summary tables it can
be used people use in production so
that's a good sign unlike Julia um but I
knew Malcolm was it and you know and
then the first thing is to use a list
comprehension to get our training
columns do it oh this is something i do
find annoying by stats models is that
you have to do things back to front
right so in in scikit-learn you would do
the X here and the Y here here you have
to do it the other way around and the
reason I'm saying this is I have spent
hours and hours like a [ __ ] not really
understanding what's happening and then
really Isaac in the documentation that
because of their the way they think
about statistical problems you have to
do a daughter way around so these are
the kind of things that we all deal with
when databases and I wish they were more
well documented I think the only way to
learn those things is either bang your
head against a wall or come to a show
about me so then you get this fit your
current function value and you have your
results summary so there's a lot of
detail and results somewhere um one
thing I had to learn whenever I was
writing this is that there's something
called serial or squared I'm value this
is the reason is that for logistic
regression you can't just apply an or
squared value in a classical context you
have to apply a hybrid mom you're a
different person call a pseudo r squared
the same kind of rules apply it has
rules of thumb and in fact in stats
models it's a mcfadden pseudos or
squared value there are other studio
r-squared values as you can tell i
really enjoy reading this stuff um I've
written it in the code for for a reason
to to have this included um and the the
take-home point for this though is that
and the rule of thumb is that is between
0 to 0.2 0.4 then is a good model right
so that you have a good model fit and
this one's a bit below this it's 0.009
so it's actually not a good model um I
think I wrote not so bad I was clearly
feeling more optimistic when I wrote
this
but this is a kind of thing you would
have right so you have these tools to
evaluate your model performance in the
same way you would valuate a machine
learning models performance and they're
all built in there and if you want them
to improve you can submit a pull request
ok so in PI mc3 there's something that's
actually very well written and easy to
use and and that's like the linear model
air syntax so you'll see here you have
your income proportional to your age
plus h squared plus education plus hours
your data log it's a binomial model in
this case and we have your samples for
those of you do not know this is called
a new you turn sampler it's one of the
next generation of a markov chain monte
carlo methods it's one of the really
like great selling points of pi mc3
because i think it's only Stan that
actually has this implemented other than
PI and c3 it's not in piracy to for
example and it's not in some of the
other frameworks all right there um I'm
not gonna run this because this model
talking like five hundred and
thirty-five seconds so just so you know
if you're about to run that I'm sorry um
um so it could take you know this is
clearly one reason why you would not use
like a Bayesian model for online
learning like because you just have
customers waiting there forever you know
so but it can be very good for like
problems that you're not going directly
into production um depending on your
definition and time scale of production
am so this is so those are you to come
from an or background this is very
similar you're losing you to use Patsy
this is very similar and it's just made
to really easy to use so like now with
particularly in logistic regression
models basing logistic regression models
we're getting very close to a psychic
learn kind of like easy to use like
numbers lines of code you know go easy
to add a stuff
this you know this is not as complicated
as the first one I show you or as your
own which everything had to be specified
individually so this is kind of like I'm
just showing this like for people who
think pi mc3 is hard it's clearly not
look I wrote it and but like you know
this stuff is here it's very easy to use
it's a nice little alternative thing if
you you know if you just don't a
frequent this one you may want to start
to do busy and frequent this one's all
the time you may not that's your choice
and I'm not gonna run this because it's
going to take forever even though i do
kinda have time I'm oh yeah right so if
you look at the auto correlation plot
for this one you can clearly see this is
rubbish right so so age for some reason
has just has not converged at all um I
don't know what's happened here and the
last one kind of worked um this is
clearly like you know so a naive model
that you know the first thing I would do
you know clearly isn't going to be
perfect so then the other thing you can
do is pick em you're better sampler or a
better starting point or let it run for
a longer period of time maybe 600
seconds isn't long enough for to
converge these are all entirely possible
these are just things you learn whenever
you're diagnosed the reason I'm showing
something that's crap is that this will
empower you to do something bills better
and that's kind of like you know the
best you can do sometimes so so then so
neither you've done this computational
effort and you've run these like markov
chain monte carlo methods one thing
you'd like to do is to actually take
advantage of the real strength of a
bayesian approach right so one of the
real strengths are basing approach is
that you always have baked in things to
do with uncertainty so in the previous
example you'll notice of the frequentist
approach you just have a value you just
have like a pseudo or squared value or
an AIC or whatever your model
performance metric is that's just a
number you don't have any clarification
Oh like the degrees of error of that
model you know you don't have any notion
of how uncertain your your-your-your
model of modeling approaches I'm really
oh this is one of the real strengths you
know of course I am up being fine boy so
I strongly polina's um but there's one
of the real strengths of a bayesian
approach so we're going to look a little
bit as some of the tools are right there
like-for-like evaluating your kind of
your model performance so I'm not going
to run this because I haven't run
everything above it but you can look at
what your distribution is off your of
your different beta things that are
coming out of your model so if you look
at this one this is up one of the plots
I made earlier on you have a you have
your posterior predictive and
distribution right this is kind of your
way of evaluating the your approach to a
model and you'll notice it at that like
that your probability of having an
income greater than 50k in this data set
is almost one if you're like 50 years
old and you went to grad school so you
can see like that like you can look at
like you know your entire distribution
here you can look it's like higher age
changes you're getting a lot more
information out of this modeling
approach and i remember it was roughly
the same number lines of code as the
frequentist approach or the psychic
learn approach rather than getting
things like precision and recall which
are the classical things in machine
learning paradigm you're getting a good
understanding of what's actually
happening here and you're different like
you know that in the different variables
that you have out there and the variable
here is high school education and
bachelors education and grad school and
this also goes in the cordons with our
intuition you would expect people who
to grad school to have a greater chance
of earning a higher salary than those
who don't but you can see also like the
kind of like these kind of tipping
points that you get with on all of these
phenomena is everyone following i'm
bored anyone yet but some people have
left but we're like Northup no questions
so just like in the frequentist approach
and we have you know we have this kind
of your odds ratio and this tells you
your probability that's something hold
on how do I explain this it's a model
performance metric for telling you how
likely an event is to happen you know
I'm but generally whenever you write
this in a frequentist way you you only
get a number rather than like an entire
distribution with your credibility
interval and the last thing I realizing
definitely finished ahead of time so
there's plenty of time for questions is
earlier on we picked age squared right
so we pick age Square to our model so
the reason we we did that was voodoo and
like I just pulled it I of my oil I
don't know where but there are actually
weighs in the Bayesian context cold
there are model performance metrics and
one of them in PI mz3 which i think i
might have contributed is a deviance
information criterion so in the
frequentist context you would have
something like an Alkin I'd alcaide
information criterion which you also
have in psychic learn as a way of
picking your model right there are these
tools in Beijing context there in pi m
63 you can use them I want to show them
also so here this this little model
thing that I've run and has k 1 all the
way up to 4 so i've done is i've applied
i've multiplied age by this exponent so
the first one's age one the first one
second one is a squared third one's age
third at HQ days for
and then whenever you run it you see
that you don't get a lot more
information like you'd need a lot more
information by going up there all
roughly the same so it's reasonable to
take just your age squared as your as
your extra variable you could pick one
of the other ones but you don't get a
teddy not a huge increase in extra model
predictive power to use like inverted
commas by going up and this is the kind
of thing that you'd use to evaluate if
you've made the right choice and this is
in the documentation as well of like of
how you would choose a different like
you know which exponents you use in your
model because sometimes you might not
have domain-specific knowledge and you
might want to use a model like a
framework your metric to help you target
that in your modeling so guys let's
actually all I have so completely you
know miss time this completely and for
that I'm I don't know what I'm sorry or
if you guys are just lucky um does
anyone have any questions was that too
fast do you want me to go back over
anything I do have times the left and or
is everybody completely satisfied and
they just want coffee well the first
thing I would do is I would run like
your map2 like to get a better one what
you can do within that is you can pick a
different solver right so often and
these are just the optimizer so it's an
optimization problem um you're trying to
commute your best starting point and
what you can use in pie mc3 so you can
use any of the syfy solver so like
there's f min Paulo there's el gfs if
you read the documentation you'll see
that like some of them have better you
know strengths and
weaknesses and I think for ya like
because there are various points like yo
CEA's and the documentation as well but
there's various points whenever I've
been building models when just simply
changing the solver had like a huge
increase like in like in the convergence
and there's clearly I haven't always had
time to go off and investigate the
really really viable theoretical reasons
for that but often it is just because of
how they solve a problem and it can be
stuff like you're to use the physics
terminology your facespace could have
like a singular ardent and then like
there are some solvers that are just
much better at dealing with that because
some of the solvers are like a certain
degree of randomness and they'll jump to
another point and then they'll find a
better starting point for you so that
would be one approach that you could
have to that sort of problem the other
thing is to just try some of the
different algorithms there are four
sampling and yeah they will have
different strengths or weaknesses
sometimes you could know from if you
have deep domain knowledge like a bike
like where these things are about word
about your starting point you can
specify it yourself I think that's
really all you have like a tool kit that
I can think off the top of my head and I
hope that was a decent answer for you
okay anybody else yeah go on
sometimes the three yes doesn't mean you
need a c compiler do you to use um some
oh that's a that's a that you I think
you do I think I'm think in particular
so if you're wrong yeah I think if
you're going to be running it on windows
or a certain architecture it's you
probably have that bit of work to do
that we haven't done actually um in
terms of siano I think piano you can
ship in a wheel or something like that
that was probably one way to include all
the sea extensions you need um yeah
because because theano compiles to see
but i def it move much should use a c
compiler of some description i don't
know which one of these does that answer
your question stalled on this mac and
i've installed on linux and you know
that's all you really need to use right
and how most um I've not had any huge
installation problems with it stay on oh
I have had problems with the ANA Theano
is very complicated right so it's it's
written in a very functional style you
can't actually do for loops and piano um
which is surprisingly annoying and you
have to use like this scanner object so
like there are an theano is also
undergoing a lot of development that in
Montreal so like the biggest problems we
had with the annual have been that it's
changing you know I'm is complicated
there was my next question um well the
API sorry
where beta is that kind of release I
don't know does anything kinds of least
these days yeah yeah hi stable is PI n
c3 it's the API is not going to change a
lot um that's being kind of like built
into the design pattern and you know
bike likes a crisp honest back and
Thomas packing so that yeah unless they
change their mind that's what that's
another thing I how I'd have to know the
right um I think the real thing pion c3
just needs to be your needs to be done
for it to be at release stage is lots
and lots of documentation which I keep
meaning to write and never do um I might
do a sprint at this event and that might
be one way and so that's one thing the
other thing is like there were a few
bugs in the samplers but that hasn't
changed the API right so so the sampler
like there's been a few bugs in that
there's a few bugs fixed recently and
then known you turn sampler but I was
only by people exposing at two different
new edge cases right so don't know if I
want to publicly say yes to that
question not um I hope so it is probably
my answer and people are I mean cuanto
P&R using it do you know Thomas is using
a quant opium you know um I don't think
I don't think they expose it directly by
thinking some of the stuff that you get
from them it's used ever any other
questions
that's a lot better than normally do i
normally take too much time this time is
up yep define production define
production I wouldn't use it for that
because the time to compute is just a
hard problem you can infer from if you
read em Cameron Davis and pylon wrote
the book probabilistic programming and
bayesian methods for hackers it's
written about by NSA too and there's a
project to pour that all that code 2 pi
mc3 which i'm looking for volunteers for
by the way um and in it he talks about
this problem right so he taught he runs
a model for what is it i think it's like
a bandit problem like so I like an a/b
testing like thing and then he takes an
approximation of that model and uses
that as a thing you had exposed so he
uses like you know an approximation for
what the model results would be which is
just something that you can compete by
arithmetic so I wouldn't recommend like
exposing a Bayesian model via a RESTful
API as like a stopping on a day-to-day
basis but most analytics does not need
to be like that so I would argue that
although like it doesn't do great in
real-time and online for a lot of
problems protecting something that's in
the internal tool or something that is
actually like analytical like type a
focused data science bayesian approach
certainly has a lot of strength is that
a good enough answer to you okay go on
go on
comment on this thing's day preservation
techniques you can use for like online
computing but I don't know if she's a
good way i can feel like a gentle
featuring yeah kind of techniques can
use for online yeah yeah i don't know if
it's easy I don't know any of packaged
like you can use in production yeah yeah
yeah yeah hoping you can look at a
beautiful subbaian particle feature yeah
there's definitely something that's on
my reading list as well so bayesian
particle filtering is what da vida just
mentioned that's so i'm not going to
explain that because i know nothing
about that i know it exists and I know
the Terrans but like I have no expertise
in that whatsoever I I know people are
I've been using it for online learning
but that's all I know I'm sorry I don't
know everything sorry it's like yeah no
yeah so if you're using like if you had
time series string you might use as a
way to do inference on that it does
strike me as a bit too complicated like
I'm Kalman filtering is a lot more well
established and the algorithms are there
yeah any other questions yeah yes
the bayesian approach to filter features
like yeah we'll see the the sort of
results i should like aft your features
you could use them and people do you
could use them like to inform your
feature selection like for a machine
learning model so yeah I've heard people
using that in the past and that's like
as a as yeah you know they use that to
get extra information about the features
as the wouldn't get from another
approach and then like pulled into a
machine learning model that they could
expose by our an API that's a pretty
good approach you see it's using
different tools but yeah yeah so I you
see a lot of the Bayesian stuff is like
a very much a or Andy as opposed to like
a Type B data science like engineering
and putting into a service because of
the nature of the beast okay is that a
good enough answer okay any other
questions go on what's my book my books
called interviews with data scientists
that's exactly what it is it consists of
24 interviews with people from Shopify
Cameron Davis and pylons in there at sea
amazon I think there's someone from
facebook but don't quote me on that
other people from all over the place and
Eric bernardston the creator of Luigi
who was a Spotify he's interviewed in
hadley Wickham's in it and a ninos valve
who runs his conferences in it as well
so for that reason you should definitely
buy it i'll put it up on the slack
channel later on any other questions
right so I think that's it Oh No yeah
distributor not to say things are
impossible Jenny cuz someone then
disproves me I look like an idiot and so
you definitely distribute the Monte
Carlo part because that's a nebari
asleep our little problem why would I
don't know if you'd want to um but
that's a different story but then the
other things like like the kind of like
getting all the information back I'm not
so sure that's the part I would i I've
trouble with I'm so distributed not out
of core right you're not talking about
our core right so I think there are
methods for like I decor to use like
multiple CPUs like in one computer I'm
not familiar with anything distributed
like like that it wouldn't surprise me
if someone's tried it I'm sure someone
is doing it um yeah I hope that's that's
all my knowledge about that yeah there's
definitely people are being taught I've
talked about it its own it's online
somewhere there's discussion probably in
PI mc3 as well but i am i'm not an
expert on that sort of stuff i try to
avoid distributed computing because it
caused me problems um that's a my own
prejudice any other questions yeah
most of the time I probably pack uniform
priors or flat priors to be honest which
is probably not a bayesian approach
actually bye-bye strike speaking and if
you have domain-specific knowledge for
those who do not know a conjugate prior
there are certain priors that we know
are the opposite to each other their
conjugate and they there's only a
there's only a few if I if I remember
off top my head like there's only eight
eight sets and in the classical text
books and a lot of time you won't have
that information if for example like the
a B when you knew that the first one was
binomial you can look it up in the table
and find your conjugal power yeah which
is some one of the inverses and you can
find that a lot of time do I do find it
as you just get more data like your
these things become less and less of a
problem it depends on what the scope is
if you have a very small data set and a
lot of domain-specific knowledge like
for example perhaps in the
pharmaceutical contacts when or a
medical statistics context when you have
like quite a small data set but a lot of
domain-specific knowledge and if you
read Cameron Davis with violence book
which is just an awesome book it does
talk about it that pecking of prior so
he has an example when they're talking
about a financial context of how you
could train traders to help you pick a
prior right so you could like make them
do a game I don't know why you do this
but I'm sure someone has like and then
gradually get a better you know like
more informative prior but the whole
prior thing is a complicated it's
probably more an art than a science of
at the moment although I'm I think there
is research on improving our
understanding of that I have theoretical
context is that a good enough answer for
you of anyone else again go on
fiction invasion that for example if
millions of observations not really a
problem for simple frequenters
approaches because efficient algorithms
are available for example if we would
like to repeat the analysis with yeah
yeah yeah so you probably would try to
take a better sample that probably be a
better approach and then trying to throw
all the data that but that's just a
sampling approach yeah and like Bayesian
approach does work very well though if
you have unbalanced like so if you
having a be tasked with different sample
sizes it works very well with such a big
problem and frequent this approach but
yeah for something like that I would
just sample from it as a first
approximation and then maybe see I love
running it on the phone thing okay
anyone else I collect y'all go night
okay right so i think that's it guys
thank you very much for listening to me
talk this early in the morning um and
enjoy the rest of the conference if you
have any questions I'm here all weekend
you can ask me about them I'm sure you
will but that's fine as we're here for
and i think that's it